Vale.
Y es que estoy mirando, estoy buscando
el instalación física en una red,
creo que está aquí.
Juraría que os lo subí o os lo pasé por
el del chat.
Tengo un recuerdo, ¿eh?
Bueno, vamos a
poner el
Vale, voy a sacar y lo vamos a pasar por
el chat otra vez.
en redes.
Vale, sí que estábamos con esto.
Vale, que estos serían los apuntes que
tenéis.
Vale, pero es que estoy buscando el
ejercicio.
Pet
preparados un ejercicio. No.
A ver si lo encuentro, eh, que es que
seguro seguro que lo que me puse a
hacerlo.
Vale,
dorm un poquillo, ¿eh?
Vale.
Este no es
esta tampoco.
tampoco.
Y aquí en una asignatura. A ver,
es que como no lo haya metido en otra
por error.
A ver,
¿no recordáis ayer si os subí algo en el
de qué?
En el chat.
A ver si lo tengo en
de redes. Creo que no. No lo sé.
No,
a mí no me a me estás.
Vale, tenemos este uno unidad 1.
Es que es una lástima porque es iba
Claro, era un poco de repaso de todo de
todo esto.
Vale, a ver si lo si por alguna
casualidad lo subí
al carpeta esta del Drive.
todo posible.
Vamos a ver.
Aquí tenemos uno entregas, pero son del
23 de septiembre. Es que no es no es
ninguna de ayer,
es como por
Vale, pues nada. Mm.
Y servicio SER como no lo haya puesto
aquí de segundo. A ver,
esto no es
valuebles.
Tac. Tac.
¿Qué falló?
Dos.
No, no, porque esto es de segundo. A
ver, a ver, este.
¿Qué va?
¿Qué va? Pues nada, vamos a a
me pongo ahí con eso porque no lo
dejaría en el escritorio. A ver.
Bu, qué mal.
A ver, a ver.
Hen
claro es que tengo
[Música]
RDSP
estaría Este,
continuamos con esto y ya está.
Y luego pues nada,
vale, tenemos,
vale, nos habíamos quedado ayer, ya es
que no lo encuentro. Vale, entonces no
se ve que me me he rayado algo y lo he
dejado en en el en el ordenador de casa.
Vale, a ver,
chat.
Y este lo cierro.
Vale, lo que voy a hacer es abrir y
cambiar.
¿Has
traído tú también? Sí, aquí
al final le vas echando peso a la
mochila.
Bueno,
leo a ver, voy a abrir el
el programa este.
Vale, ya estamos.
Vale, estábamos en habíamos llegado
hasta máscaras de su red. Vale,
estábamos viendo lo de la parte
la parte de red y la parte de host,
¿vale? Pero no sabíamos todavía el por
qué llegábamos hasta eso. O sea,
entonces,
a ver, que me sitúe.
Vale, habíamos quedado en que la parte
de
la parte de red es la parte de la
dirección que identifica de forma única
la red completa a la que pertenece el
dispositivo.
habíamos hecho la analogía de de con un
con el sistema postal, ¿vale? Y veíamos
que la parte de red lo que nos
identifica sería
la población
y si me apuras, bueno, la calle ya no,
porque la calle ya pertenecía a dentro
de la población. La parte de red nos
podría en analogía postal podría ser el
código postal, la población y la
provincia si me apuras.
¿Vale? Y luego la parte,
o sea, los router
serían como oficinas de correo que solo
mira esta parte para tomar decisiones
cruciales. Su trabajo, el trabajo de un
router sería preguntarse, ¿está el
destino en mi misma red o es en una
remota? Si la parte de red es la misma,
los dispositivos están en la misma
redenicarse
directamente. Si es diferente, el router
enviará el paquete hacia otra red.
Generalmente, pues eso, hacia internet,
¿vale? Y la parte de de host serían la
calle y el número,
¿vale? es la es la es la parte de la
adicción que identifica de forma única
un dispositivo específico. ¿Os acordáis
aquello que decíamos de eh calle mayor
número 67? Puede haber en 50 pueblos
diferentes, pero pero claro, la calle
mayor número 57 de Alcoí solo está
solo existe esa. ¿Vale? Entonces, eso sí
que sería lo que,
a ver, la sería sería eso el equivalente
a la calle, el número y el piso, por
ejemplo. Pues eso, lo que os he dicho,
la calle mayor 67, tercero B. Esto
distingue tu casa o la dirección de de
lo de tu vecino en la misma ciudad, no
sé, o sea, el tercero B no sería el
cuarto B, obviamente. ¿Vale? ¿Para qué
sirve? Pues una vez que un paquete de
datos ha llegado a la red correcta,
gracias a la parte de red, el switch o
el punto de acceso wifi desarre utiliza
la parte dejos para entregar los datos
al dispositivo exacto que los está
esperando. El móvil, o sea, tu móvil en
este caso o tu ordenador en vez del tu
hermano o hermano.
¿Vale? Y lo que habíamos visto era esto,
era el la parte de red, que sería esta
de aquí.
Espera, ¿cómo se
vale, ¿dónde estamos? No sé dónde están
las opciones.
Vale, aquí.
Vale, esta sería la parte R,
¿vale? De esta dirección,
¿vale? es una dirección típica de de una
red local. Pues aquí teníamos la parte
de red y la parte de host sería 50. Este
50 es lo que definiría tu tu host, o
sea, tu dispositivo,
ya sea un móvil, ya sea
ya sea una una tablet, ya sea una
nevera,
un, no sé, el dispositivo que queráis,
¿vale?
Vale, que tienen en común todos estos. O
sea, imagínate que tu red sería la red
de tu casa 192, 1681 51 52 53. Depende
de cómo se hayan asignado, ¿vale? Pero
esto es habitual. De hecho, eh, podemos
abrir Packet Tracer y ver
y ver el tema este, o sea, lo ahora lo
abriremos, ¿vale? Y lo veremos y veremos
el tema de de máscaras de red también
así con con Packet tracer, ¿vale? Que
que sí que nos va a servir para todo
esto, ¿vale? ¿Qué tiene en común todos
estos de
todos? Pues la parte de red, si veis, no
me he dedicado a copiar la parte de red
porque es lo que tendrían todos en
común. Imaginar una lista hasta el 254,
¿vale?
Cuando tu consola le pide un vídeo a
YouTube, el router de tu casa, ves que
la dirección de YouTube
888,
o sea, 8.8, 8 sea la dirección del DNS
de YouTube, o sea, de de
Google, por ejemplo,
de YouTube, no, no es de Google, ¿vale?
Tiene una parte R completamente.
Entonces dice, "Este paquete no es para
mí, red lo envío a internet."
¿Vale? En cambio, cuando quieres
imprimir un documento, tu ordenador,
que sería el 50, como hemos dicho, envía
los datos a impresora, que podría ser el
53, ejemplo. Entonces, el router ve que
ambas direcciones comparten misma parte
de red.
Comparten la misma parte de red.
Entonces, comunica
con la 53 sin necesidad de
salir a internet.
Vale, pero es la identificación que hace
sería esa. ¿Vale? ¿Cómo hace este
identificación? Pues gracias en parte a
la máscara de de su red, ¿vale?
Que es donde nos habíamos quedado ayer,
que sería esta sería la máscara de
subred para esta dirección IP.
Vale, ¿cómo sé dónde termina la red y
dónde empieza el host? Vale,
vale. ¿Cómo sabemos? O sea, imaginaos
estos este, o sea, al final estamos
hablando de una de una expresión
binaria,
¿vale? Entonces, este 255, ¿qué
significaría?
este 255, ¿qué significaría
en en binario?
Que tenemos 81 unos,
¿vale? Que su posición
tenemos 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 y 8.
Este de aquí lo mismo. Vale.
A ver, ¿por qué tenemos 81? Pues pues
porque el valor, o sea, a ver, espera,
el valor de esta posición vale uno. Este
vale dos, este vale 4. Este vale 8, este
vale 16. Este vale 32. Este vale 64.
Este, ¿cuántos he puesto? Cuatro.
Vale. Y este vale puesto nu más. 128.
Vale, entonces tenemos que
la suma de todos los valores nos da 255.
Sí.
Vale. Entonces aquí tenemos lo mismo.
Aquí más de lo mismo. Ostras, qué mal
dibujo. Un 2 3 4 5 6 7 y 8. Y aquí
tenemos ceros.
Vale, ¿qué qué significa? Que estamos
utilizando
8* 3 24 bits para esa para esa dirección
IP,
¿vale? Quedando ocho libres. En esos
ocho podemos implementar hasta 200.
son 256
porque el cer el cero y la última no
la utilizaríamos, ¿vale? Para asignar
direcciones IP.
Tenemos tenemos eso. O sea, aquí
podríamos podríamos asignar 254
direcciones,
¿vale? O sea, que queda queda claro que
la primera la primera que sería en cero
y la última que sería 255, esas quedan
excluidas.
Vale, esto sería la la
no sale ahora la esta la
mm
o sea, el nombre de la red, ¿vale? Como
si así dijéramos,
¿vale? Y esto se se y la última se
utiliza para broadcast, para para envío
de datos entre entre la red.
Vale, más cosillas. Eh,
¿alguna pregunta aquí?
No, vale,
vamos.
Vale,
vale. Ahora vamos a ahora vendremos
aquí, o sea, vamos a poner esta esta
dirección IP.
100 aún no lo sabemos, pero en base a su
a, o sea, así no podíamos calcular la
máscara de red, pero vamos a vamos a
abrir packet tracer y ahora ahora
veremos
dónde lo tengo.
Francisco,
a ver, realmente lo podíamos mirar en
más sitios. Calculadoras de de máscaras
de máscaras de y un montón.
SP
A ver, estamos estamos en Packet Trer,
¿vale? Entonces, habíamos dicho que
teníamos la vamos a íbamos a averiguar
esto. Ahora veremos el por qué. Vamos a
crear
un
un dispositivo
cliente, un host
y vamos a asignarle
una IP que sería la que hemos puesto
aquí que sería la 10.
5 pun 20 pun 100 y ahora él
automáticamente nos calcula la máscara
de red que sería esta 255.0.0.0.
O sea, eso ya no es tan habitual como
estas que estamos acostumbrados a ver,
¿verdad?
O sea, porque a ver, es que no no como
no actualiza bien el el este, este lo
vamos a dejar así, ¿vale? Entonces
vamos a crear otro.
Nos venimos aquí de esto. Aquí le
ponemos 192.16.
Est la típica, ¿vale? 168
punto, ¿cuál habíamos puesto aquí? uno
punto 1 punto uno también. Vale,
entonces máscara es su red, ¿vale? Esto
es más, esto es más, o sea, esto es lo
que estamos acostumbrados, ¿no? Vamos a
saberlo.
Este tipo de este tipo de de máscara R.
Vale, luego quiero que os fijéis en otra
cosa, o sea, en esta
veis la dirección IP que le hemos que le
hemos asignado, que es la 10 20 18.
¿Veis el la el slash 8 que tiene al
lado? Eso nos está indicando
a que ya a qué clase pertenece. O sea,
ahí nos está diciendo que 8 bits
están ocupados en la en la máscara de
red, ¿vale? Por eso tenemos el 255
como sub como máscara de red, ¿vale? Es
una manera de
de ver también esto, ¿vale? Si nos
venimos a esta.
Espera, a ver, si nos venimos a esta,
vemos que tiene ocupados 24 bits,
¿vale? Su máscara de red es la típica
255 como hemos visto antes, 255 2550
para se su a ver son las que utilizamos
para solemos utilizar para redes
locales,
más que nada por eso, porque realmente
aquí puedes incluir
un número manejable de dispositivos.
La pregunta,
una pregunta
en una red
eh que tuviera que tuviera 16, o sea, en
esta red, por ejemplo, a ver, co,
eh,
Vale, en esta, por ejemplo,
hasta cuántas direcciones podríamos
podríamos implementar
en esta que voy a crear ahora.
Vale, en 170
punto eh
150.12
pun
10.
Vale, en esta red hasta cuántas
direcciones podríamos implementar.
Sí. ¿Cuántas cuántas dispositivos
podríamos podríamos tener en esa red?
Tenemos ocupado todos estos bits de aquí
y realmente lo que tenemos son 16
barra 16.
Los tenemos ocupados nos quedarían 16
libres. En 16 bits, ¿cuántas redes nos
cambian? Pues tendríamos que hacer una
multiplicación. de los 255
por 210, o sea,
serían unas aproximadamente unas 65,000
por ahí.
Es que tenía el número por aquí.
Permite. A ver.
No tenía calculado, pero bueno.
¿Habéis calculado alguien? Os dará eso
no me imagino.
Que cuánto por cuánto es
porque realmente sería tendrías que
añadir, hombre. A ver.
256 * 256
serían 65,536.
Estamos añadiendo el cero inicial
a los 255.
Vale, continuamos.
Vale, direcciones. A ver,
estábamos en la máscara. Queda claro lo
de la máscara de de red.
Bueno, más o menos.
Más o menos. Sí.
Vale, ¿alguna duda de
Vamos a ver?
Por supuesto, o sea, ni de coña nos va a
ser si tenemos IPs diferentes y ahora
conectáramos aquí y tal, o sea, esto no
funcionaría, ¿no? Porque diría, "Esto,
¿qué qué me estás contando
aquí? Cada uno va por un lado. O esto,
¿qué es? Bueno,
claro. A ver, la idea, la idea básica es
que cuando tú veas esta máscara,
en este caso
pun 0.0.0,
¿vale? Sepas que que seguro va a
pertenecer a esto. ¿Por qué me dirás?
Porque mira, es que claro, nos falta un
poco la otra parte de la historia, que
es desde qué dirección IP hasta qué
dirección IP se considera de una clase o
de otra.
Vale, tendríamos
las eh las de rango, o sea, las de clase
A
iría desde
desde el uno. A ver, vamos a ponerlo
aquí.
El primer obteto iría desde el No, que
es aquí por abajo. Vale, el primer
obteto clase A
iría desde el uno
al 126.
Vale, buscar todas las
todas las direcciones IP de todos los
de todos los de las páginas web así más
cañeras y tal, bueno, más cañera y todas
os van a empezar por
por esto, ¿vale? El
el las de clase B irían desde el 128
al 191.
¿Y esto por qué esto no me deja? A ver.
Vale, sigue ahí. y las de clase C
del 192
al 223.
Vale, entonces aquí sí que entonces una
red,
esta red 192.168.20
[Música]
20 punto
pun0. ¿A qué pertenecería?
A la C.
A la C. Correcto. La Bueno, 8.8.8
por 127.
127. Es que no, espera, es que esto,
Vale, luego tenemos las las apipa. Vale,
ahora lo vemos también.
Un segundillo.
No sé es que 126 me está
clasificación
está es que
vale es que no, claro, es que ya decía
yo es 127
cuando estaba escribiendo digo, ostras,
esto no me no me suena a mí.
Vale, luego 128 y 192 hasta 223. Luego
tendríamos las de la clase D. Estas
direcciones se usan para multidifusión,
enviar datos a un grupo de dispositivos
y los primeros bits empiezan con 1110
que ahora ahora lo lo ampliamos,
¿vale? y clase que se reservan para
experimentos de investigación,
etcétera.
Vale.
Eh,
vale, exacto. Una C.
Vale, vamos. Sí, espera.
Vale, vale. Y esta, a ver si la sabéis,
la 169.
21 por ejemplo, al que pertenecería
no esto sería una dirección a pipa se
llama, ¿vale? cuando tu router
o, o sea, cuando no tienes dirección IP
es la que se te asigna automáticamente.
A lo vemos también, de hecho mío.
Creamos un
Vamos a crear un
un switch. Vale, vamos a conectarlo.
Vale.
Y ahora en el momento que reciba,
supongo que
le ponemos un router si eso.
Este mismo.
Solo
valeos
aquí.
No. Nada.
He.
pasando aquí.
¿Ves? Una dirección a pipa sería 169
254. Cuando te encuentres eso es que no
te has dado el, o sea, es que no tienes
no tienes cuando, o sea, cuando está
configurado para tener una dirección IP
automáticamente y no encuentra un
servidor que se la asigne, se se asigna
a sí mismo una IP automáticamente, que
sería esta.
Vale, cuando te encuentres eso es que no
te ha asignado una IP y va de ese rango
del 169 254 01. Espera
por aquí.
pipa sería
de la 169
dos,
perdón, 2
1 a la
2 5 4
pun 254 cuatro.
Vale, continuamos.
A ver, íbamos por,
Vale, estábamos por
estábamos por direcciones públicas.
Vale, ahora nos faltaría al tener las
direcciones públicas.
Bueno, entonces esto queda claro, ¿no?
Más o menos tema de máscaras de red y
tal, sabemos luego, o sea, hay multitud
de recursos por internet que te
de calculadoras de de lo que quieras.
te calcula la máscara de suplón
te la pasa
esa decimal
o sea lo que quieras
no está de más que todo esto se la IA
por supuesto nos lo hace también a veces
a veces mal
vale pero no está de más que sepamos
cómo cómo funciona todo esto, no es que
no esté de más, o sea, es que debemos de
saberlo,
¿vale? Eh, tipos de direcciones IP,
¿vale? Las direcciones únicas y globales
en todo internet, o sea, que son serían
direcciones únicas las direcciones
públicas, me refiero, que que son
direcciones únicas y globales en Twins
es imposible que dos dispositivos
diferentes en el mundo tengan la misma
IP pública al mismo tiempo.
¿Vale? Y eso es un concepto que que debe
quedar claro. A la vez que en una red
local tampoco podemos tener dos
dispositivos con el con la misma IP,
¿vale? En un entorno global como sería
el de las direcciones públicas sucede
exactamente lo mismo. ¿Quién las asigna?
Pues eh tu proveedor de servicios de
internet, tu ISP, Mobi Star, DG.
eh Vodafone o todos estos.
Ellos compran grandes bloques de
direcciones y te asignan una o unas
pocas a tu router. Son necesarias para
salir a internet. Es la dirección que ve
el resto del mundo cuando navegas.
¿Vale? ¿Y para qué sirven? Pues son
imprescindibles para cualquier
comunicación que salga de tu red local.
Cuando visitas Google, juegas online o
usas una red social, los servidores de
estos servicios ven como el origen de la
petición,
digamos, algo así como que es el número
de matrícula de tu de tu rut,
¿vale? las direcciones privadas, que
siguiendo un poco con la analogía de la
casa, las IPs privadas son como los
números de las extensiones telefónicas
internas.
¿Habéis llamado alguna vez a un número
con extensión?
Marcas el número y luego pones la
extensión.
Bueno, eso existe, sobre todo en los
fijos, o sea, si tienes que llamar un
hospital o una gran empresa, tú marcas
el número y a continuación la extensión
y te lleva directamente a ese
departamento.
Bueno, pues la son como los números de
las extensiones telefónicas internas,
son números que se repiten en millones
de oficinas, pero que solo, o sea,
quiero decir, imagínate la tú llamas al
un ejemplo
62 54 12 45. Imaginar que no es un
móvil, que es un teléfono fijo y además
tiene la extensión 458.
Vale, esa extensión 458
puede que se replique en cientos de
miles de teléfonos que tengan
extensiones. Bueno, la 458 quizás no
porque es muy alta, pero la extensión 5
o la 05, por ejemplo, se replicarán en
millones de oficinas de todo el mundo,
pero
a nivel local solo existe ese.
Vale, como estamos hablando de una
dirección privada,
pues estaríamos hablando únicamente de
esa de esa dirección, ¿vale? Como tú
previamente habrás tenido que marcar el
número, pues ya va encaminado hacia
hacia la hacia la hacia la extensión, o
sea, ese número tiene esa extensión,
aunque esa extensión luego se se repita
en muchos en muchas oficinas. Vale, ¿qué
son? Estamos hablando de direcciones
privadas, direcciones reservadas para su
uso en redes internas o locales, la red
de tu casa, el instituto, una empresa y
no tienen validez en internet.
No son enrutables en internet. Si un
paquete con una IP privada como origen
llega a un router, a un router de
internet, esto lo descartará
inmediatamente.
Es como si intentarás enviar una carta
usando solo extensión 101 como
dirección. El carte sabría a qué
edificio llevarla.
Vale, pues y la ventaja principal sería
la reutilización. Como son solos para
redes internas,
yo puedo usar, por ejemplo, 192, 168,
110 en mi casa y y vosotros podéis usar
exactamente la misma la tuya. De hecho,
es que posiblemente tengáis tengamos
todas las mismas en a no ser de que
hayamos trasteado en el router y hayamos
añadido otras
otro rango de IPs.
Lo más seguro es que todos todos
tengamos la misma
bien cero, bien uno,
pero todos vamos a tener la misma,
¿vale? Y esto es lo que ha permitido que
el que el limitado,
¿recordáis que estuvimos ayer hablando
hasta cuántas direcciones se podían usar
con IPV4 y cuántas con eran si no
recuerdo mal eran como 16 millones no
4000 4300 millones de direcciones y vale
pero somos 8000 millones de de personas
en la tierra y dispositivos ni te cuento
ya.
Porque hay quien más y quién menos en
todo el mundo, digo ya a nivel global, o
sea, salvo en salvo en pocos sitios, o
sea, es que tenemos un montón de
dispositivos conectados a internet
y ya no estamos hablando de primer
mundo, segundo mundo ni tercer mundo. O
sea, es que da igual, da igual. está
demasiado globalizado el tema de las de
los dispositivos,
¿vale? Y esto en realidad es lo que ha
permitido que el limitado
IPv4 siga funcionando a día de hoy.
¿Vale? Eh, ¿cómo se conecta a internet
entonces las estas direcciones IP
privadas? pues mediante un mecanismo
llamado NAT en traducción de dirección
traducción de dirección de red en del
router. El router traduce las
direcciones privadas de todos vuestros
dispositivos a la única dirección
pública cuando salen a internet
y hace el proceso inverso cuando llegan
los datos de vuelta.
Es como si el portero, o sea, en
analogía, ¿vale? El router recibiera un
paquete para la puerta
para la puerta 13 y supiera que es para,
o sea, es como si el router recibiera un
paquete para la extensión 101 y supiera
que es para el despacho de Juan.
Vale, imaginemos que que estábamos
hablando de extensiones.
Pues eso, ¿vale? los rangos, lo que os
he dicho, los rangos
privados más importantes.
Sí, vamos a vamos a poner otra tabla.
Este serían las clases, ¿vale? Y luego
los rangos que se utilizan. Espera que
tire para abajo todo esto, ¿vale? Luego
rangos.
de direcciones
privadas.
Ya ves,
serían de clase A.
10 punto 0.0 0 punto 0 a la 10
Esto sería para redes muy grandes, redes
muy
grandes.
Vale. Luego
de B,
la clase B sería la 172
a la 10
a la 172
sería para redes medianas.
Y la C,
o sea, de clase C
sería la 192
168. Hasta suena ya, ¿eh? 0.0 0 a la
192.168
255. Vale. Y esto sería para redes
pequeñas.
Vale, esto sería lo que se suele lo que
se suele utilizar. No quiere decir que
tú
que tú lo cojas y digas, "No, no, yo mi
router lo voy a configurar con
metiéndole la 198 no sé qué, o sea, en
red interna, quiero decir, ¿vale? Porque
una cosa es lo que te, o sea, tú puedes
crear redes realmente como
o sea, lo que tienes que tener en cuenta
es el número de dispositivos que vas a
que se van a a enganchar a esa red. En
base a eso ya calculas.
Vale. A ver,
redesores,
¿vale? Deciros que las redes de es
así de gran tamaño se serían usadas por
grandes corporaciones o proveedores.
Permite
aproximadamente más de seis más de 16
millones de dispositivos de dispositivos
por red.
Vale, estas de aquí, las siguientes, las
de clase B, redes medianas, ideal para
universidades o empresas, hombre,
medianas, medianas, no serían, sería
empresas tochas,
¿vale? Pero una universidad que tiene un
montonazo de alumnos, por ejemplo, la
UPV, pues no sé, estará en torno a los
50 60.000 alumnos.
Mira, voy a mirarlo.
Upv alumnos,
número de alumnos y luego la la
Universidad de Valencia, pues también
otros tantos.
Vale, en la actualidad
está formada por más de 39,000 miembros,
de ellos cerca de 34,000 son alumnos,
3600 profesores e investigadores y 15 se
entrenan al grupo, o sea, un huevo de
gente, ¿vale? Y de la de la Universidad
de Valencia, pues lo mismo.
Tiene más, ¿verdad? La Universidad de
Valencia.
Pues daros cuenta, o sea, estos tipos de
redes los utilizarían de universidad,
sería muy lógico que lo utilizasen,
¿vale? Y luego las pequeñas,
que es
pues es el que todos tenemos en casa.
Permite hasta 254
dispositivos por red,
más que suficiente para una casa.
Vale, entonces a ver, direcciones a
pipa. Vale, cuando un dispositivo,
lo que estábamos hablando antes de las
de las apipa. A ver que la subraye aquí.
Vale,
cuando un dispositivo está configurado
para obtener IP automáticamente y no
encuentra un servidor que se la asigne,
se asigna a sí mismo una IP
automáticamente que se que iría en este
en este, perdón, en este rango,
¿vale? lo que hemos dicho antes,
eso ya. Hm. Pues nada, ahí ya os saltan
todas las alarmas cuando estáis
configurando cosas,
¿vale? Y ahora, si queréis
vamos a vamos a identificar
estos tipos de red que el DNS de Google,
por ejemplo, sería la 888,
o sea, 48 por punto sería como una
dirección IP,
¿vale? ¿Cuál vamos a hacer?
Vamos a hacerlo un pin.
8.8.8.
Vale, este sería la
la
el DNS de Google, que también sería el,
si no recuerdo mal, era cero.
Esto no sé si era cero o era o era uno.
Creo que es este. O era cuatro.
Era cuatro. 4.4.8
Cuatro se mosquito bien.
Vale,
a ver, espera, voy a poner aquí
8 punto
pun Cuatro.
diría que es la 8.1.
Vale, pues si queréis vamos a a ver eh
estas estas direcciones IP
y vamos a determinar que es cada una, o
sea, por ejemplo,
8.8.8
8.8
que es es el DNS,
nombre de dominio
de Google,
o sea, el servidor de dominio, perdón,
de dominios
de Google. Esta sería pública,
¿vale? es es de sería pública y de clase
de clase G, ¿vale? O sea, perdón, de
clase A. ¿Vale? Luego tendríamos
esta, ¿qué sería?
192.168.
101.
Esta sería
C
de clase C.
privada.
Vale,
esta otra vez. 1 6 9
2 5 4
15 80
seguía
esta sabe alguien lo que sería
a pipa.
Sí, correcto. sería pipa,
¿vale? Y luego tenemos,
por ejemplo, esta 172.17.254.1
sería
clase B
de clase B, correcto.
Y privada.
Sí, exacto.
De clase D.
y privada.
Vale, y tendríamos esta. Por último,
ponemos esta otra, ¿vale? 85
eh
que sería
público
pública. ¿Y qué?
pública
y de y sería a
esto porque ha desaparecido los números
Essensible
el lapicillo este.
Vale.
Bueno, pues entonces, claro, yo me había
preparado para después de esta clase una
serie de preguntas para que las fuéramos
haciendo,
¿vale? Pero veo que que no lo encuentro
por ningún sitio,
¿vale? Si queréis
ir repasando un repaso,
¿vale? Una IPV4 que es una dirección de
32 bits
que identifica a un dispositivo en la
red.
Se escribe con cuatro números.
separados por puntos.
Tienen una parte de red y otra de host
definidas por la máscara. O sea, la
máscara de red es lo que realmente nos
dice que es la red y que es el host. Eso
yo, a ver, esto quizás lo más importante
de todo. ¿Os ha quedado claro eso,
verdad?
Sí.
Si no recalcamos ahí. Vale, vale.
Gracias.
Y luego pues eso, o sea, que existen
direcciones, direcciones públicas
y para internet y direcciones privadas
que serían para redes internas y luego
el caso extraordinario las apipas cuando
no hay conexión.
¿Vale? Y ya está. Eso sería más o menos
el resumen
de lo que hemos estado viendo y me da
una rabia que no tener los ejercicios
esos.
Vale, pues si queréis
eh podíamos hacer un ejercicio con el
pack tracer.
A ver que pienso un poquillo
en el que Sí, a ver si hay aquí algo en
el temario.
Es que sí que estuve viendo aquí.
Vale, esto es interesante también que lo
veamos. Vale, esto no está mal.
Vale, ¿qué es una subred? Por ejemplo,
ahora que ya conocemos lo que es una una
dirección IP,
¿vale? O sea, otra vez un identificador
único asignado a cada dispositivo,
conectado de internet
que que pues eso te permite comunicarte,
intercambiar datos.
Sin las direcciones IP, internet no
funcionaría tal y como lo conocemos. O
sea, me imagino que funcionaría de otra
manera.
No sé cómo, pero pero funcionaría de
otra manera. Otros sistemas se habría
inventado, eso seguro.
Vale, las se dividen en dos tipos. Esto
lo hemos visto al principio, lo vimos
ayer, que eran IPv4, IPV6
y que los proveedores de internet los
ISPs que te ofrecen realmente ambas
versiones. O sea, realmente si hacemos
un IP config,
es que no sé si lo si lo hicimos ayer,
IP Confi,
ahí sí que vamos a ver,
¿vale? nuestra dirección IPv6,
en este caso sería esta
y la y la yo tengo la 60 establecida,
o sea, imagino que el servidor
pues estará configurado para que cada 8
días la cambie la IP porque recuerdo que
estaba en la 45 al principio del curso,
ahora ahora estoy en la 60,
¿vale? Vale, y esta realmente esta
dirección la que nos lo está
nos lo está facilitando es el router
mediante mediante el protocolo de HCP.
Los que estáis en segundo posiblemente,
o sea, los que los que ya habéis hecho
la asignatura sí que os sonará todo
esto, pero a lo mejor a los
a los que vienen de
de no vienen de de hacer el primero,
pues
son conceptos y y siglas nuevas, ¿vale?
Las direcciones IP son jerárquicas y se
dividen en cuatro o seis partes llamadas
obtetos. Lo hemos estado mirando antes,
cada sección, antes o ayer, cada sección
representa información diferente y back
en la asignación de direcciones IPs
gestionadas a través de protocolos de
enrutamiento.
Para garantizar una transmisión de datos
exitosa, los protocolos de interconexión
facilitan la comisión la comunicación de
las redes IP.
Vale, las eh el proceso depende de la
conectividad en la red. La subdivisión
se utiliza para dividir las redes en sus
redes más pequeñas, optimizando el uso
de direcciones IP.
Vale,
vale, ya entraremos a desgranar también
las las IPV6, o sea, ¿qué significa cada
cosa aquí? que aquí sí que estáis viendo
que estos que esto corresponde, o sea,
estos estos primeros números
corresponderían a la dirección IPV4.
Luego aquí no nos lo pone, pero esto de
esto la cabecera sería el código del de
la región,
región o país, no recuerdo ahora muy
bien. Tendría que que mirarlo,
pero vamos, lo que nos está indicando,
esto está en tal sitio y su y su
dirección es esta. Luego sí que va
seguido una serie de números, no acaba
aquí. O sea, al final son 128
frente a los 32
de una IP, ¿vale? Que es una subred.
Ahora que ya conocemos el tema de las de
las de las direcciones IP, pues una
subred también conocida como como
subnetwork, bueno, llamamos subred. Es
una división lógica de una red IP,
¿vale? La subdivisión se refiere a la
práctica de dividir una red en múltiples
redes más pequeñas.
¿Vale? ¿Para qué necesitaríamos nosotros
dividir una red en sus redes más
pequeñas?
Pues sería una manera de optimizar y de
y de tener
de,
¿cómo diría? de hacer algo más,
o sea, la red podríamos hacer la red de
una forma más
fácil de de trabajarla,
¿vale? O sea, se eso se sí podría ser
podría ser algo así,
¿vale? Generalmente lo podríamos hacer
una empresa con varios departamentos,
pues cada departamento tendría su propia
subred. Eso podría ser porque su red y
no velan pues porque lo haríamos con con
un router y sí que necesitaríamos esa
proximidad física que no nos daría una
vez, pero bueno, aquí ya nos podemos
meter en otros conceptos y vamos a ir
paso a paso, ¿vale? En el caso de una
IPV4,
una red puede ser identificada por su
máscara de sul red,
que es una máscara de, como hemos estado
viendo, es una máscara de bizit aplicada
a una dirección IP mediante una
operación
de anitabit para determinar el prefijo
enrutamiento, por ejemplo, considerar el
prefijo 190 214/
o sea 0/24 que tiene una máscara su red
de 255 255 255 que no lo que nos está
indicando aquí la máscara de su no pues
este 24 de aquí es crucial
las máscaras de suelen representarse en
notación decimal con puntos o sea a ver
os quiero decir esta esto es crucial
porque nos está diciendo que este más
este más este son tres obtetos que suman
24 24 bits que está utilizando la la
máscara de
la máscara de red, ¿vale? Las máscaras
subred suelen representarse en notación
decimal con puntos. Otro ejemplo es 192
barra 212 donde se asignan 21 bits para
el prefijo de red,
¿vale? Y 11 bits restantes se reservan
para la dirección de host en la red
IPv4.
Cuando los prefijos de enrutamiento en
las direcciones de origen y destino son
diferentes, el tráfico se dirige entre
sus redes a través de enrutadores.
La suddivisión pueden mejorar la
eficiencia del enrutamiento y
proporcionar ventajas de administración
de redes. ¿Correcto? Esta sería la
palabra, antes, administración de redes,
especialmente cuando diferentes
entidades dentre una organización más
grande tienen control administrativo
sobre sus redes específicas.
Vale, ¿cuál sería la diferencia entre
IPV4? Bueno, es la extensión
principalmente,
¿vale? Porque mientras IPV4 es de 32
bits, la otra es de 128. Esto lo vimos
ayer, creo. Vale, que nos salía una 300,
¿cuánto eran? 360 de estillones o no sé
qué es que era que eran cuatro eh
trillones.
Lo tengo por aquí.
Mira, 340 estillones.
Todo esto de aquí
frente a pues eso, lo que nos podría dar
la IPV4.
Si no existiesen, si no existiesen redes
privadas, la IPv4 realmente nos daría
4300 y pico millones de direcciones IP.
Vale, sería 2 elevado 32. ¿Por qué dos?
Porque es binario. O sea, sería eh
esto nos daría los 4294
millones de direcciones IP y esto nos
daría dos dos porque es binario elevado
a 128 nos daría 340
340 estillones
y pico.
Esto hay que decirlo también. Vale,
para los consumidores, el significado
práctico de esta diferencia de tamaño es
mínimo. Las direcciones IP suelen
aparecer como cadenas de números
separados por puntos.
Hoy en día la mayoría de de ordenadores
admite tanto los protocolos IPV4 como
IPV6, por lo que la elección de qué tipo
usar al navegar en línea suele ser
insignificante.
¿Quién necesita comprar estas
direcciones?
Vale, pues incluso si no posees tu
dirección IP aún puedes obtener una de
compañías especializadas que los venden.
Al igual que las empresas se aseguran de
que sus ubicaciones físicas sean
fácilmente locales, perdón, localizables
en un mapa, también desean que sus
direcciones IP se comuniquen claramente.
Las empresas compran grandes bloques de
direcciones IPV4 para asignarlos entre
sus sucursales y otros sitios.
lo que facilita a los clientes y posible
software encontrarlos en línea. Al
asignar un número IP único a cada sitio,
las empresas garantizan que su sede
tenga una dirección IP reconocible
y disponible para los visitantes que
busquen su información en línea.
Un segundo.
Vale. E
línea, vale. Muchos tipos diferentes de
empresas requieren un número
significativo direcciones IP, incluidos
proveedores de servicios de internet,
empresas de aloj
de de alojamiento, servicios en la nube,
servicios VPN.
perdón, diversos negocios en línea y
servicios bancarios
y de pagos.
Vale, la mayoría de las direcciones IP
son propiedad de registros de internet
locales. Lir por sus reglas, por sus
siglas en inglés
que obtienen espacio IP, registros
regionales de internet
en bloques para uso privado dentro las
regiones geográficas específicas.
Cada cada R eh registros regionales de
internet es responsable de gestionar la
disponibilidad de espacio IP, registrar
cuentas para asignación dentro de esos
espacios y determinar la asignación de
bloques de direcciones IP. Los cinco
riarir son serían los siguientes,
¿vale? Este sería para América
anglosajona,
especialmente en América del Norte,
obviamente.
Vale, este sería para Europa.
Centro de Coordinación de Redes IP
europea, responsable de la
administración del espacio de
direcciones IP en Europa,
el LANIG, que es un registro de
direcciones en Asia. y Pacífico,
regiones de Asia Pacífico,
América Latina y Caribe sería esta de
aquí, la la
y la obviamente esta sería para África.
Vale, aquí tenemos un mapa con las
diferentes
los registros regionales de internet con
las diferentes
con las diferentes zonas y a donde
pertenecen.
Bueno, esto lo hemos estado viendo,
redes públicas y privadas.
Aquí tenemos otra definición. redes
públicas son son redes que pueden ser
accedidas y utilizadas por cualquier
persona sin restricciones de acceso.
Estas redes están diseñadas para
proporcionar servicios de de
telecomunicación
o un gran número de usuarios como
internet, televisión por cable, radio,
etcétera.
Red radio MFM. Ah, bueno, pues será
escuchar la radio por internet. Bueno,
sí, vale. Pues en Netflix, todo lo que
se os ocurra.
Vale, redes privadas son redes que están
limitadas a un grupo específico de
usuarios,
una empresa, una organización, una
familia. Ya hemos visto que puede haber
diferentes tamaños aquí, o sea, es puede
ser desde inmensas corporaciones con
miles de de puestos, con decenas de
miles de puestos hasta la red de tu
casa,
¿vale? Estas redes están diseñadas para
proporcionar comunicación y compartir
recursos entre los dispositivos
conectados, pero no están abiertas al
público en general.
Vale, aquí tenemos las características
de cada uno.
Vale, están eh redes privadas están
diseñadas para proporcionar comunicación
y compartir recursos dentro de un grupo
específico de usuarios.
Eh, están limitados a un grupo de
dispositivos y autorizados y no están
abiertas al público en general.
Vale, ejemplo, redes de una empresa,
¿no?, ¿vale? Es lo mismo que hemos
estado viendo aquí, ¿vale? Diferencias
y ejemplos.
¿Qué ejemplo nos da? Vale, luego hay una
tabla muy chula de en la que sí que la
estuve viendo,
¿vale? Diferencias. Las redes, las redes
públicas están abiertas al público,
mientras que la es lo que estamos
repitiendo y todo el rato, mientras que
las redes privadas están limitadas a un
grupo específico de usuarios.
Las redes públicas tienen medidas de
seguridad para proteger la privacidad y
seguridad de los usuarios, mientras que
las redes privadas pueden tener medidas
de seguridad adicionales para proteger
información recursos compartidos
y eh configuración. Las redes públicas
figuradas para proporcionar servicios a
un gran número de usuarios, mientras que
las redes privadas están configuradas
para satisfacer las necesidades
específicas de un grupo de usuarios,
¿vale? Aquí tenemos un cuadro resumen,
¿vale? Pero no, lo que yo os quería
decir era en la en la web de la de Tame.
A ver, es que lo vi el otro día y
buscaré este ejercicio y os lo os lo
pasaré,
¿vale? posiblemente suba uno evaluable
sobre esto en estos días, pero vamos,
tranquilos que no va a ser para este
puente, o sea, será a largo, ¿vale? Será
para Si estamos ahora
estamos a 7, la siguiente actividad de
las creo recordar que estaba para el día
15,
¿vale? Sí. Topologías de red cierra el
el 15 de octubre. la actividad
evaluable. Importantísimo, o sea, os lo
vuelvo a recalcar, importantísimo
hacerlas que luego os hace media.
Eh, abriré otra con lo que hemos estado
viendo.
Os pondré el el cuestionario no
evaluable, uno no evaluable y otro
evaluable. El no evaluable lo veremos el
el lunes por aquí y estaremos
habrá preguntas y respuestas,
¿vale? Lo corregiremos y el y el
evaluable pues lo tendréis pues yo que
sé hasta el día hasta el
si este está hasta el 15, pues el
siguiente lo pondremos hasta el 22, me
parece, hasta el 22 de octubre o así. Me
parece razonable.
Vale, el siguiente ejercicio evaluable
de relativo a esto.
Vale, pues
os lo dejamos aquí hoy
con esta asignatura y nada, que tengáis
feliz puente.
Muchas gracias. Igualmente.
Vale, a vosotros.
Hasta luego.
Adiós.
Pues como que no está ni
A ver, espera que cierro. Yeah.